bon maintenant ça suffit tu prends la
prochaine sortie et tu t'arrêtes
docteurs ont fait là je crois qu'il peut
passer à l'acte et techniquement c'est
bien ça c'est un mytho ils veulent
empêcher de retrouver ma mère ce n'est
pas amis tôt je suis psychiatre à
l'hôpital je sais remettre mythomane que
ce sera quelqu'un qui va passer à laguna
les valoriser en ituri toi je chie
dessus
arrêtes ta bagnole abouti tu te
rappelles nous et ça va pas oui je suis
pas sur ma mère pour fiasse visons les
enfants c'est dommage
est ce ton courtois mais pas de cool
mais l'outil avec toi ou je fais mon
père aussi
c'est vraiment pas trop les yeux c'est
quoi
vous faites partie d'une secte services
collectifs ça recommence et ça
moi
c'est ma mère je peux
oui maman kate rien à craindre le fusing
un corner
monsieur valeurs sûres
c'est parti
mais c'est pas que ça c'est la voiture
du futur
et vous avez le régulateur de vitesse le
régulateur de vitesse et non
daniele déchets dont john monsieur dany
ryser a traversé le pont fait désactiver
le régulateur de vitesse et suffit de
freiner sa le désactive automatiquement
dysfonctionnements le voyant avait cette
arnaque parce que là si vous freinez
d'état que et tonneaux garantie monsieur
comme vous n'avez qu'une chance sur
résiduelle de vous en sortir
c'est à dire aucune 6
pour la révision de véhicules américains
à bientôt
priorité au direct star
login habituel qui se déroule sous
l'oeil des caméras de bfm tv
une voiture folle qui semble ne pas
vouloir s'arrêter et qui a déjà posé de
nombreux dégâts sur l'autoroute
danielynn née sept ans john messieurs
dames élite qu'on fait pour désactiver
le régulateur de vitesse il suffit de
freiner sa le désactive automatiquement
qu'est ce que tu as fait
on ne peut pas s'arrêter c'est dans la
boîte un fusil
thème peut-on une voiture soit sur le
ton est ferme et bloqué facebook a et a
pas d'autre solution
vous n'êtes pas trop le capitaine ça va
un peu d'humour besoins en capital et
biens publics
les comores dans l'océan claveau la
personne va trouver une solution mais
tout ça
si tu as de la joie au coeur tape dans
tes mains les enchante 2 je viens de
parler avec les services techniques
des touches ans soeur résiduelle de vous
en sortir aucune
ah les pompiers prague fait sa mue
autoroute info tous les coups